[Musique]
karine trappe c'est le nom de cette
jeune maman de 36 ans originaire de
nîmes en grève de la faim depuis le 1er
mars
karine trappe à en est à son 40ème jour
de grève de la faim c'est à dire qu'elle
est en danger de mort
depuis 2016 elle se bat pour récupérer
la garde de ses deux enfants noah 13 ans
et samuel six ans voilà plus de quatre
ans qu'elle est au coeur d'une longue
bataille judiciaire avec ses douze
anciens maris chacun père d'un enfant
guy contre elle et qui tente de la faire
passer pour une femme violente là où je
me pose la question c'est pourquoi les
institutions continuent à accabler cette
mère en réalité c'est lui-même qui
serait violent et manipulateur puisque
toutes ces allégations seraient
mensongères
pour karine cette grève de la faim de la
soif et la dernière chance de faire
bouger les choses et de revoir un jour
ses enfants ce soir elle est avec nous
pour lancer un appel
marchi karine d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup
karine qui se bat donc depuis de longues
semaines pour récupérer la garde de ses
enfants
ses seules armes la faim et la soif elle
ne mange plus depuis 40 jours
elle risque aujourd'hui sa vie voit très
amaigris karine 40 jours
karine après quatre ans d'enfer et de
souffrances et de harcèlement judiciaire
vous battez donc pour aiguille pour
récupérer la garde de vos enfants tout a
commencé en 2016 quand vous portez
plainte contre le père de votre deuxième
enfant samuel pour dégradations domicile
et violences physiques
qu'est ce qui s'était passé à l'époque
alors effectivement j'ai déposé plainte
en octobre 2016 après avoir décidé de me
séparer définitivement de lui
c'est à ce moment là qui s'est rapproché
du père de fiche de votre première map
de mon premier enfant avec y avait des
relations pas mirobolante mais on va
dire cordiale et donc j'ai déposé cette
plainte
ensuite lui j'ai appris plus tard a
fourni des photos que j'ai jamais vu
j'aime ce que cette plainte va se
retourner contre eux ça va très
certainement qu'il a fourni des photos
qui avait quoi sur ces photos alors des
photos que j'ai vu quelques années plus
de deux ans après des photos il a le
visage totalement tuméfié en fait et en
fait vers de votre deuxième report voilà
c'est ça et il
il a prétendu que c'était vous oui vous
le bâti oui c'est ce qu'il a vu ses
photos il dit
vous les aviez cheville au goût je les
ai vus pour la première fois en août
dernier avant de passer en procès donc
vous allez être finalement reconnu
coupable il pas victime est le père des
deux enfants et les pères des deux
enfants vont tout faire pour vous
retirer la garde de dire qu'ils se sont
alliées tous les deux oui alors là ils
sont même devenus très amis aujourd'hui
leurs vacances noël anniversaire voilà
donc pourquoi ils se sont ligués contre
vous tous les deux ils sont 10 en une
alliance on va récupérer les enfants ils
ont pour me fournir des fausses preuves
de ce que vous dites c'est ce que vous
dites alors les fausses preuves c'est
spécialement le père de mon fils cadet
d'accord là le premier peur est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il a il a fait état de deux
violence de votre part aussi ou pas du
tout par contre il avait été condamné
pour avoir deux trois fois un peu pété
les plombs on va dire intérieurement
mais ça c'est pas mieux
j'ai même pas fait référence pour le
coup mu était reconnu et violent des
rappels à la loi antérieure d'accord et
ils vont gagner
ils vont gagner et la garde de vos
enfants vous a été retiré c'est en 2007
en 2007 en 2010 est exactement 2017 que
vous perdez la garde de vos enfants
ça c'est maintenant un top 4 en plus de
4 plus trois ans oui bientôt quatre ans
est ce que vous voyez vos enfants
aujourd'hui quand même alors le petit
samuel alors il ya une erreur dans la
lah mon fils yann et ses 11 ans d'accord
donc le petit qu'à six ans samuel je le
vois deux fois par mois au mieux pendant
1h30
il faut que je fasse huit heures de
route aller retour pour le voir et noir
je me voyais dans les mêmes conditions
jusqu'à plus récemment et là je le voir
en plus de ces visites médiatisées donc
c'est dans un lieu clos en fait je suis
jamais seul avec mes enfants et pour
noah depuis peu j'ai des visites libres
en supplément donc je peux sortir
quelques heures avec j'ai pas vu mes
enfants ensemble depuis trois ans du 3
au 28 mars au fond tous les deux en même
temps
alors le premier était placée dans un
foyer à alès il ya plus de deux ans et
le second donc biche et son père en
lozère son père celui qui avait fourni
des photos que vous dites fausses et des
fausses photos d'après tas selon vous
alors depuis que vous avez puberté
médico légal
ouais ouais c'est ça non mais si et
c'est que ça que c'est ça qui est
incroyable comment ça c'est que vous
perdez rien alors en fait les expertises
le problème c'est qu'elles ont
j'ai vu les photos très peu de temps
avant le procès et selon les expertises
médico-légales leader ils ont vu que
c'était pour eux c'était le destin voilà
c'était des photos qui étaient biaisés
après même l'un des deux experts est
formel sur le fait que ce sont des
automutilations quoi ah oui et donc
et comment comment se fait-il que
pendant le procès ça c'est un et pas été
prises en compte alors des soucis en
particulier à la cour d'appel de nîmes
ça a déjà été dénoncé plusieurs fois
dans la presse
c'est à dire que c'est juger vraiment à
la va-vite quoi les personnes d'ailleurs
de mon entourage qui était présente à ce
procès à chaque fois que j'essaie de
parler de ces photos là on m'a demandé
de me taire clairement mon
interprétation ce serait qu' on a la
garde de mes enfants c'est à dire depuis
tellement longtemps je suis tellement de
bruit revenir entre guillemets que
c'était facile et peut-être un moyen de
valider a posteriori tout ça voilà que
je perde tout crédit au niveau justice
au niveau médiatique depuis que vous
avez perdu la garde de vos enfants vous
battez pour les récupérer il ya déjà eu
19 décision de justice dans cette
affaire puisque ça puisque tout contre
vous alors tous confondus à la presse
que même une centaine de garçons tout
contre vous ces décisions alors pas tout
puisque en 2017 début 2017 quand les
papas donc ont attaqué
il ya des décisions qui ont à faire ma
faveur clairement donc
la guerre du mot restait et même le papa
de samuel s'est vu refuser une extension
de ses droits de visite
voilà la juge avait été assez claire
voyante en fait et ça a basculé en
l'espace de quelques quelques mois quoi
quand on madame quand on regarde la
faire on a l'impression d'une
machination contre ouvrit deux paires la
justice et toutes ses décisions dans
cyril parlait le système social pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que tout ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'on vous en jeu de temps madame
c'est ça c'est vrai que c'est incroyable
alors à vos marges
moi je constate après l'interprétation
de pourquoi quel est le but de certaines
personnes je peux pas vous le langage à
elle directement ce que je peux affirmer
c'est que le but de du papa de samuel se
venge et ça c'est très clair
malheureusement il ya eu l'intervention
des services sociaux et puis pour garder
un petit peu ce qu'est ce que sont les
placements invisible d'enfants en france
c'est assez catastrophique
donc je vois là un concours de
circonstances certainement et puis après
les magistrats qui veulent pas
reconnaître leurs erreurs quoi donc ça
karine voilà les gens sont aujourd'hui
vos enfants ils ont six et 11 ans sont
une idée de la situation qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent les enfants ils veulent
venir avec vous est ce qu'on leur a
demandé leur avis aux enfants c'est là
une question vraiment qu'ils me qui est
super parce que benoît qu'on lui demande
son avis ou pas son discours est
toujours le même à chaque appel
médiatisé donc devant témoins éducateurs
évidemment de la rentrée tout le temps
tout en tout temps je suis chez sa mère
mes doigts qui est le plus grand qui a
raison qui voilà qui posèrent balisés
voilà exactement et même six ans samuel
il doit s et c'est un peu compliqué à 6
ans mais je pense que là dans ces cas là
c'est quand même il faut quand même
demander l'avis aux enfants ils ont 6
ans et 11 ans surtout pour le plus grand
si vous dites qu à chaque fois il veut
rentrer chez sa maman je comprends pas
que les autorités et les personnes
responsables voilà ne prennent pas en
compte le rôle ravi alors aujourd'hui
vous avez décidé de faire une grève de
la faim à quel moment vous dites c'est
le seul moyen de me faire entendre
à un moment de tout afin de voir comme
ça les années passent et aucun progrès
presque quatre ans environ 80 sont les
vrais et la santé ma mine de rien quand
vous êtes sur mené parce qu'en plus de
ses décisions il ya aussi le surmenage
d'avoir devoir aller à gauche à droite
de plus pouvoir travailler vous
travaillez plus je peux plus travailler
les et les visites elles sont elles
changent quasiment toutes les semaines
l'ag rappelle parce que vous êtes vous
avez un nouveau compagnon aujourd'hui
oui vous êtes dans cette caisse qui dit
que de votre grève de la faim parce
qu'il doit être inquiet quand même il
doit être inquiet pour votre santé comme
nous alors l'ironie de l'histoire c'est
qu'il est docteur faim médecins deux
d'accord alors oui mais bon donc il vaut
ici c'est de surveiller tout ça ah oui
on est il au quotidien avec moi mais
encore des sacrifices vous dit quoi ils
vous dis pas que c'est vous mettez en
danger
c'est humilier très régulièrement et
surtout les gens même ce que vous
attendez parce que là ça fait quarante
jours quand même mais reste de la forêt
tant sa barrette est ce que vous sentez
que ça bouge ou pas du tout
médiatiquement je vous remercie vous
faites partie des personnes qui
réagissent au niveau judiciaire c'est le
silence total soit parce que silence
total
on a vous citerai que l'avocat alors
j'ai une avocate pénaliste elle qui
bougent beaucoup mais malheureusement
les délits pénaux sont pas ceux de
civils en fait c'est un chrono
fait d'ailleurs une interview publique m
rhodia way la firme voilà que ça
aboutira mais il ya plein de gens
pourquoi notre vos infos qui est placé
en foyer
alors en 2017 mes enfants fait une
petite période envoyer ensuite chacun
chez leur papa donc ça mais lui est
resté 2017 quand vous avez perdu la gare
voilà lui d'abord ils ont fait 3 mois
d'observation va dire je veux bien le
papa qui veut avoir le qui veut
absolument avoir su où ils sont mais si
c'est pour le mettre en faillite est
libre alors c'est pas pas si vraiment je
pense qu'il ya encore quelque chose à
tirer de ce papier peint il est en fait
c'est pape et les malades c'est bien
maintenant mais voilà ça c'était le
premier ça c'est le papa louis denoit
voilà bientôt plus grands oui donc lui
il peut plus de toute façon le petit peu
avec les références en fait mais ce pops
le papa de noix il dit pas il n'a pas
envie de vous le récupériez noah n est
pas mon fils il envie d'aller avec sa
maman est-ce que je vais pas tout faire
pour qu'il aille avec sa maman est-ce
que je vais pas essayer de faire le
nécessaire c'est un peu lui passer un
petit message ce serait bien que je
pense que la clé là si votre premier
mari vous me dit en plus qu'il est qui
qui est plutôt de bonne constitution
afin qu'ils aient qui vous convient pas
qui c'est quelqu'un qui on peut discuter
est ce que vous pensez pas que si lui
dis moi mon fils je préfère qu'ils
soient chez sa maman quand foyer même
s'il ya des foyers vraiment et les
personnes qui travaillent en foyer cqp
extrêmement bien des enfants au tri
mais c'est vrai que si nos en plus vous
êtes avec sa maman est-ce que c'est pas
la solution et signe alors là je pense
que claire moyens l'intervention du papa
de sa mairie qui pose un gros problème
donc le club de 2ème appel à elle comme
ils sont tous les deux bien il a une
grosse influence sur le premier papa le
deuxième sexe est le problème il faut
alors est-ce que vous avez essayé de
parler directement aux premiers pas et
les services assure le papa s'appelle
dans le pronom danois pas de noix là il
ya coupure de contact total et le
problème c'est qu'un des motifs de
replacements c'est le fait qu'on
n'arrive pas à s'entendre de ça moi je
vais firme clairement qu'il ya certains
intervenants sociaux et entretiennent ce
conflit a fait pour continuer enfin peu
placement perdure sur les accès ce
problème là et régler la placement
l'enfant qu'ils allaient quel est vôtre
quel est votre solution aujourd'hui
kelly quels sont vos motifs d'espoir
est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez
pouvoir récupérer vos enfants au moins
nos à ce qui est en foyer assez
rapidement ou pas du tout si je fais ça
c'est que j'y crois je ne dis pas non
plus les jours passent plus on se
demande quand même quand ça va arriver
que là je commence passé les trente
quarante jours ça commençait sa crème 40
jours à des grands parents à qui on peut
parler ou à qui vous pouvez parler les
parents des papas vous voulez dire alors
en fait le papa de no âge il a très très
peu vu ce qui est même étonnant que
d'ailleurs de noël a été confiée dans un
premier temps les grands parents sur
l'autre bout de la france j'ai très peu
de contacts on a eu pendant les
premières années de nos âmes et c'est
vrai que ces rondes et une seule est
rompu et puis
de bernard montiel madame trappe votre
autres voulaient nous dire et
bouleversant et on est de tout coeur
avec vous évidemment on partage votre
douleur et et l'absence de vos enfants
évidemment mais sauf qu'il ya une loi et
c'est quand même la loi est un croyant
pas ce que l'autorité parentale et peut
être retirée aux parents quand ça
représente un danger pour son enfant
donc ça a été traité plusieurs fois et à
chaque fois on est revenus là dessus que
répondez vous à ça c'était ça se trouve
parce que vous avez eu quand même vu
bah oui on a eu plus de dix neuf
décisions de justice a oui à chaque fois
on est revenu sur le même sujet en
statique crédit cds qui avec toujours la
même
alors pas mise en danger de l'enfant
tous les manques de soins à olaya jamais
il ya plein de choses non mais bien sûr
bien sûr c'est difficile à croire alors
pour moi j'ai toujours l'autorité
parentale
il n'aura qu'un foyer donc je suis censé
pouvoir prendre les décisions etc
dans les faits l'on est pour ces mails
me suis vu retirer l'autorité parentale
alors je précise que j'avais fait déjà
une première grève de la faim en 2018
pouvez vous expliquer pourquoi j'aurais
est arrivé là et en fait dans la foulée
à peine arrêté je me suis fait retirer
l'autorité parentale les procédures
pénales ont commencé pourquoi retirer
l'autorité pas retiré assez petit
pour mes activités parisiennes du québec
j'ai pu aller aux visites pendant
quelques semaines avec sa gueule et sai
par exemple samuel s'est cassé le fémur
chez son papa moi j'étais pas joignable
ce jour là puisque preuves à l'appui
article de journal il y avait une
coupure de réseau dans le village
il a essayé de me joindre ni par mail ni
mon entourage etc et ont alors que
j'avais plus envie de recommander en
disant si un jour il ya un souci voilà
appelle-moi par tous moyens je veux je
veux c'est une urgence pour samuel et il
a réussi à faire croire comme ça sur ces
simples paroles que j'avais pas été
joignable ce jour-là une plein de petits
détails cumulé mes activités parisiennes
le fait que j'ai pas été joignable ce
jour là voilà ça suffit pour être sur
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale en
cas de chaleur l'autorité parentale
karine on espère que ces témoignages ici
dans touche pas à mon poste va faire
bouger les choses et surtout moi ce que
je vois je vous dis je pense que là la
chose à faire
urgemment ses demandes et la vie vendée
enfants et je me doute noah 11 ans qui a
un avis sur avec qui il a envie de vivre
si dit qu'il a envie de vivre avec sa
maman je pense que voilà il faut il faut
éviter
il faut écouter l'enfant merci karine
d'avoir été avec nous fait attention
quand même à votre santé merci moi on
sait que votre nouveau compagnon lui
avait dit et médecins mais n'est pas
magicien
voilà exactement en fait attention est
vraiment moi je pense que là vous avez
fait à sept jours de grève de la faim
vous avez fait vous allez entendre
je pense que maintenant il faut être
aussi raisonnable parce que les enfants
font ils ont envie de voir leur maman
mais ils ont envie d'avoir en bonne
santé donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la bonne solution maintenant vous avez
fait passer votre message
je pense que maintenant il faut que vous
passiez voilà il faut que vous repreniez
une vie j'ai envie de dire entre
guillemets normale et que vous essayez
de vous battre par les différents voilà
mode de la cour ici vous sont proposés
mauvais différents recours parce que là
c'est votre don vous allez être mettre
votre santé en danger et je pense pas
que le petit noah ni le petit samuel ait
envie d'avoir une maman voilà qui sont
en mauvais état d'accord merci merci
merci merci